[Music]
what did various here in the flames is
the question many fans have been
wondering for years and it's the
question I'll try to answer in this
video burst was born across the Narrows
seen lies he was born a slave and as a
child he Jarrell with a troupe of actors
all around different free cities until a
sorcerer in the city of Myra made an
offer various his master could not
refuse Varys was sold to a sorcerer who
gave him a potion that made him unable
to move or speak but did not doubt his
perceptions or sense of pain and
emasculated him cutting off his own main
parts so he could use it in a magical
ritual burning them in a brazier and the
sorcerer threw where's his genitals in
the brazier the fire turned blue the
sorcerer called and the voice replied
very screwed a voice in the flames that
shook him to his core but Game of
Thrones has never revealed what that
voice said season six came the closest
embarrassed encountered the red
priestess Kamara she hails from alanis
which is very Sanchez said she's now
going in season seven in season six key
noir appeared to know what that voice
said and very clearly found her
unsettling she told him everyone is what
they are and where they are for a reason
terrible things happen for a reason take
what happened to you Lord Varys when you
were a child
if not for your mutilation at the hand
of a second-rate sorcerer you would not
be here helping the Lord chose him bring
his light into the world knowledge has
made you powerful but there still so
much you don't know do you remember what
he heard at night when the sorcerer
tossed your parts into the fire you
heard a voice call out from the flames
do you remember should I tell you what
it was said should I tell you the name
of the one who spoke it served the same
queen if you're hurt you friend you have
nothing to fear from me that's the scene
in which Amara is fairest about the
voice in flames that he heard when the
second-rate sorcerer to his man parts
into the fire
she asked if he knows who was speaking
on the other side making Barry
speechless not only because she knows of
this major event from his life but also
because she apparently knows who was
speaking very soul very visible shaking
was this became Mara he wants her to
repeat for him those same words or to
identify the speaker for him the word
search verse doesn't
here again let me repeat one particular
part that she taught various everyone is
what they are and where they are for
reason
terrible things happen for a reason take
what happened to you lord varys when you
were a child
if not for your mutilation in the hand
of a second-rate sorcerer you would not
be here helping the Lord's Chosen bring
his light into the world I have been
wondering what conveyor going to imply
on when she said if not for your
mutilation would not be here helping the
Lord's Chosen Kim are obviously man that
if not for his mutilation he would not
be helping Danny right now but I'm
wondering is it because of the voice in
the flames that varies heard there again
all the power that he has and is he
helping Danny because of the words
because the voice told him to I'm aware
that it's hard to find any Curt answer
on this but this theory in which the
voice that came out from the flames
thought varies to serve him and help
Danny certainly is an interesting theory
while we know for sure that various
Gary's revenge as we saw seen in the
fourth episode of the third season in
which we could see the various was
clearly torturing that same source heard
at once tortured him a scene itself
explained much more in that same scene
very sad meta to Tyrion that he heard a
voice and that he still dreams of that
night the night when all of that
happened to him he also admitted that
it's not because of sorcerer or his
blade that he dreams of but because of
the voice from the flames in the books
Varys does not even know what he heard
that night when Mary described the
haunting story of his castration he said
when the sorcerer to his parts into the
fire he heard a strange voice speaking a
language he could not understand and
also said that he was drugged and in
pain pointing out that he often told
himself that he must have hallucinated
voice well this is the case in the books
I don't think it's the same in the show
in the show very said himself that he
still remembers the voice additionally
he studied Jim Soviet every now and then
which kind of confirms the very snows
what voice said and by his face
expression when Kamara asked him I'm
quoting you heard a voice call out from
flames you remember she I tell you what
voice said it was pretty obvious that he
knows and that he exactly understood the
words that came out from the flames but
let's assume that just like in the books
words did not understand what the voice
said on a TV show as well it would still
be obvious that various who can be
considered as one of the most clever man
in Seven Kingdoms would learn that
language rich the voice spoke would
learn and so the meaning of those words
since he still knows and dreams of that
voice so yes it's most likely the Taurus
knows what we said exactly and in my
opinion that same voice is the reason of
Aries being on the place in which he
currently is and the reason of him
helping Danny Targaryen since the very
beginning
some believe the was actually told where
is how and very is he going to die no
Sanjay might have hinted that versus
most mysterious secret just before
departing for valannus it's reasonable
to assume that no Sanjay could also know
what the voice in the flames said to him
she's easily as powerful as Kim are and
likely even more powerful after all she
resurrected someone and it's a known
very keen Marquez Oda Melisandre does
not directly make reference to where's
his childhood or the voice he heard in
the flames she does say something very
ominous I have to die in this strange
country just like you the response verse
looks as honored as he was with keen war
in season six it seems probable that the
voice in the flames told him something
about the date or nature of his death
knowing that in advance we'll be hunting
for anyone there's also a theory that
this whole various Avengers as a hint -
where's being someone far more important
let me know someone of royal blood in
that theory Varys is the last member of
house Blackfyre that is considered to be
extinct by the time the series takes
place george RR martin and showrunner
Selma's confirmed that Varys is a
highborn is someone of a royal descent
it's only people with royal blood are
being used in magical rituals it might
be a confirmation that various Kings
blood a blood that has tremendous power
in magic where is being used in a
magical ritual confirms fairies being of
royal descent which affect that upon the
sorcerer - his main parts in the fire
resulted with the voice being heard from
flames confirms the statement well this
fact that I mentioned could be
considered as a proof there's also one
more than interesting fact and it's the
fact that sorcerer stank is cut out we
can see that in a fourth episode of the
third season in a scene in which where
it's introduced Theory only the sorcerer
they tortured him in his youth Earth's
probably carried out himself in order to
either keep it secret of being a
Blackfyre or in order to keep the words
and raps the second hint is in the fact
that various keeps his head shaved
which he might be doing in order to hide
his hair colour which virtually is a
black fire should be platinum blonde as
it's one of the traits passed on the
black fires by the Targaryen if true
this would be a
major twist it's not only with one of
the main characters turn out to be
someone else but it would also be a huge
betrayal over Danny as the black fires
are infamous for the repeated and
unsuccessful tense sort of the Targaryen
dynasty in a series of conflicts
collectively known as the Blackfyre
rebellion it was more than enough for a
huge amount of fans to assume that Varys
is about to betray Danny if it truly is
a black fire the first clue that might
go in favor to this theory in which
Varys is not loyal to Danny's in Kumar's
confrontation or where's a hint that a
huge amount of fencer considering as the
probe airs not being loyal towards day
and using Kumar's next time and that
she's said to eros she said we serve the
same queen if you're hurt you friend you
have nothing to fear from me so
basically in history the voice said the
words spoken from the flames are not
that important the whole event serves as
a huge hint towards being a Blackfyre to
conclude this Terry there's certainly a
small possibility of errors being a
Blackfyre even though I don't think is
mostly because of the fact that
showrunner decided not to enclosed or
even mention the black fires throughout
six seasons and therefore very snug
being a black fire probably would not
have a reason to betray Danny
me personally I'm almost sure that Varys
is and will remain loyal to Targaryen as
he's been loyal to tag areas his whole
life and as he's been working on a plan
to bring back their gaming house the
unknown that has been taken from them
ever since the destruction of House
Targaryen now I'm not saying very soon
not switch sides for another Targaryen
Jon Snow even possibly work on a plan to
have Danny killed in order to secure
John the Iron Throne but the point is
very Sistine Targaryen going into season
eight verse will continue to serve
Targaryen sent he will most likely make
a new Allegiance that will provide them
thousands of soldiers and it's going to
be bit nonetheless David sir says only
lies in the golden company Conleth Hill
an actor who plays various T's that very
still be as effective as always in
season eight what it means Sandford
shadows is very stirring the gun company
against her saying yearn persuading them
to fight for the less Rhaegar son aegon
targaryen since that role black red the
dragon is still a dragon we've been
listening over and over again how the
cooling company have never broken a
contract that then breaking it and
supporting Targaryen seems like such an
obvious twist of the final season
additionally the Gullah company have
already broken the contract in the books
and the guest who was the reason at
garyun last but not least we have a
theory that the voice first heard from
the flames was brain the day he was cut
very scared a voice from the flames just
like horror her brain a day Ned left for
the hearing just like Ned hurt brain
when he was going up the stairs of the
Tower of joy very skirt brain the show
establishes that people here brain from
the future the seeming in marathons
various about the voice he heard from
flames nsima he wants to know what the
voice said is in famous the door episode
and literally comes right before the
scene where brain becomes the three-eyed
Raven fence even go that far to claim
that brain the new trade raven is in
fact the lord of light himself one way
or another we will get an answer to what
the voice was and what it said in a
final season probably in the same scene
Maris dies one of the biggest mysteries
will definitely be unfolded let me know
in the comment section who do you think
spoke to Eris and what do you think the
voice said to him and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace